if there was gonna be a one shot like
just you guys what would you do in if
you could pick like 15 minute like a
one-shot kind of scene you guys are a
little adventure what would you go out
to hmm I'd like to see her teach Bucky
how to dance yes I was just thinking
that you do you know what the Milly rock
is no okay so it's a dance that was
created a little while a good in this
song's called mini rock and you kind of
have to just it's like you're like
whooping flies right so on set I was
teaching him how to do the Milly rock
with one oh that is oh that was later
yeah the arm came back yeah right when
he ya know they know I had the arm great
secret no but with the arm yes yes the
arm he was mini rocking so I think we
would have a dance competition we will
learn you know learn a few things you
know we ended them the lake so it would
take like boat rides and stuff we'd go
on the bone yeah just like yeah yes a
little lake trip yeah nice that sounds
amazing
she would have Bucky like redo the
Titanic I'm the pain in the world
she'd be behind she'd be the jack you
guys have some of the best half I would
say in the MCU arguably with you well
spin your best kind of hair look what do
you think I mean you've been here for a
while like I feel like we've really
gotten it pretty well in this film I
mean you know given the trajectories of
Bucky's Harry yeah it's been pretty good
I remember when I remember when we did
our scene and Ryan was like and I was
like no you know I kind of like what is
there a word for when there's when it's
down but then there's like half up
and then you give you were contemplating
how's he gonna do but you all the window
soldiers also I feel like he could
handle yeah
so obviously you guys are in and out of
makeup all the time um what's been like
for both of you what's the best kind of
beauty hack to keep yourself looking
glowing and fresh after the beam end so
after the end of the shoot exfoliating
mmm Black Panther world taught me about
the importance of exfoliating I I would
go home and get some some really nice
scrubs and just scrub out all of it all
of this may be the dust that's been you
know had a big day of fighting scenes
and on top of that they put makeup on
the shot as she always looks beautiful I
was to tell you go out there and get
sleep obviously I'm not a good
representative had said don't look at me
for that don't like sleep is the way to
go
you gotta get sleep sleep water in
exfoliation yes
hydration they sound like absolutely
amazing and fruits yeah and what would
you so Tom Mullen said recently he's got
into trouble a bit and he's not like he
wasn't allowed to go wasn't allowed to
read the full script was that the same
for you guys like when you were doing it
were you allowed to it were you like in
you know you didn't know what happened
or how that work you would give me your
scenes or wheel that I was just only
giving my the scenes that I was in I
didn't read i i I've never read the
whole script so and you still haven't
seen it it's nice to see that others
have oh isn't it hmm do you think that
is you're less trustworthy and others
more trust for me became a noise
spoilers
[Laughter]
my apologies my apologies it was just
that it was not give it to us nobody
receive this they're like you're in a
freezer anyway right now yeah yeah yeah
and I suppose like even before like do
you have any idea what the name of
Avengers 4 is like I think we can guess
them see I've had a few guesses as well
well he says so I was like okay Avengers
disassembled haha
Avengers what is that there's like been
just could be that was me that was
actually some from Twitter so I have to
imagine us Avengers or like I feel like
we haven't had a lot of Hawkeye and I
feel like plot twist Avengers Hawkeye
reborn or it'll be something very
obscure like the 37th stone Oh
Avengers Thanos back I'm still here I'm
going nowhere thank you so much I'm very
excited for this maybe and obviously
Avengers big thank you that was fun